salut aujourd'hui on teste un nouveau
format si ça vous plaît on continuera à
le faire et comment je serai si ça vous
plaît bah simplement avec le nombre de
vues qui fera la vidéo le nombre de
likes c'est à peu près ça ne repère pour
savoir si ça vous plaît ou pas j'ai
toujours adoré les histoires de pierre
bellemare ça fait longtemps que
j'aimerais en faire un concept de vidéo
et puis je pas pris le temps ça fait
deux ans qu'on en parle ici au bureau et
son arrivée les traits d'horreur est ce
possible c'est peut-être le moment de
s'immiscer dans ce game alors vous aimez
l'horreur ne s'est pas un trait
d'horreur mais c'est un peu comme un
trade pour cette première vidéo on va se
concentrer sur l'histoire d'un homme
celui qui a réussi à vendre le paradis
loïc générique de ce nouveau format
on va partir un petit peu en arrière on
va aller en 1885 à rennes-le-château un
nouveau curé arrive là bas il a été
envoyé il s'appelle bérenger saunière et
il a été envoyé là bas pour des raisons
très particulière en fait l'église et de
huy ont un problème alors que saint curé
dans l'église ils disent qu'il a des
idées un petit peu trop avancé un petit
peu trop moderne et puis il a tendance à
à défier un petit peu l'autorité est un
petit peu insolent donc il envoie là-bas
pour une raison très simple c'est le
pire endroit c'est la pire église qu'ils
aient saisi au moins là-bas il va pas
trop nous saouler donc lui il arrive là
bas il trouve une église qui est
quasiment en ruine le presbytère c'est
là où habite le curé est quasiment
inhabitable il n'y a pas grand chose qui
va et la raison elle est très simple de
tout ça c'est parce que le village est
très pauvre donc quand les curés fonda
ken buck a pas beaucoup de revenus donc
un moyen de thé enclencher des travaux
lui il arrive devant l'église il se dit
waouh c'est quasiment une ruine il
arrive et il n'y a rien qui va parce que
il ya même un côté très désagréable
quand il rentre il rencontre un gros
bénitier robin thicke dans les églises
mais la caisse soutenu par un diable qui
le tient comme ça
l'ambiance à l'ehpad amdh pourtant à la
base ce n'est plus dans un bon élément
bérenger saunière glénan 1852 et il a
été le meilleur élève du séminaire de
narbonne il parle le grec le latin
l'hébreu vraiment tout va bien sauf
qu'il a tendance à gangréner un peu la
jeunesse avec les idées que l'église
trouve trop avancé à l'époque arrivé
là-bas sony refait les comptes il lui
reste à peu près 600 franck a laissé son
prédécesseur
c'est pas une énorme somme pour l'époque
c'est une belle somme en vrai mais pas
pour faire tous les travaux qui auraient
à faire mais avec ses 600 francs bay
dans de restaurer un petit peu l'église
et déjà de la faire fonctionner en fait
tant que
de pourvoir vivre accueillir les fidèles
etc et il prend une première décision
qui extrêmement choquant pour l'époque
il engage une jeune femme de 18 ans et
sa femme marie dénarnaud en tant que
gouvernante ça se fait pas tellement
surtout en plus dans le village qui est
pauvre il n'ya pas des moyens et c est
pourquoi c'est choquant parce que il
cache pas trop qu'ils ont une liaison
ensemble donc ça ne va pas du tout avec
le fait d'être curé pourtant le village
a l'air de s'y habituer ça a pas l'air
de poser un grand souci en tout cas dans
le cadre du village mais tout le monde a
compris ce qui se passe 1891 c'est là où
tout va commencer l'abbé décide de
restaurer l'hôtel qui à l'intérieur de
l'église donc pour ça il va faire venir
des maçons avec quel argent il va faire
ça il est allé voir la mairie il a
beaucoup parlé il a attendu pas mal de
temps il a réussi à obtenir un prêt 2000
francs de la part de la mairie pour pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée me lefranc
énormément d'argent pour l'époque
surtout dans ce village parce que
saunière l'année d'avant il avait réussi
à récolter 25 euros mais je veux dire
sur toute l'année avec les quêtes qui
fait à la fin des messes donc là il va
pouvoir un peu avancé dans les travaux
donc il engage deux maçons les maçons
arrivent ils vont commencer par essayer
de desceller l'hôtel du pilier sur
lequel il déposait les arrivées à l'est
des scellés et la surprise derrière la
pierre il ya toute une gravure en fait
la table de pierre a été montée à
l'envers donc derrière on découvre une
sorte de cheval en face c'est un cheval
qui tient à s'être c'est une gravure
assez étrange et surtout deuxième
surprise le pilier datant des wisigoths
et creux et à l'intérieur on trouve
trois boîtes et pas mal de parchemin
autour des boîtes et pour moi c'est le
début où ça devient vraiment étrange
parce que saunière chasse littéralement
les deux maçons et l'inde paraît dégagée
par tei leur paie quand même les deux
jours de travaux même si l'on fait à
peine une demi journée et il leur dit
d'aller boire des coups avec à sa santé
enfin y il les veut vraiment plu ici et
les deux maçons évidement qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un chemin ces boîtes est ce
qu'il ya dedans et tout est dit mais
vous inquiétez pas assez des reliques y
en a toujours dans les piliers des
hôtels mais il est fou littéralement
dehors donc les ouvriers sont bien
obligés de partir ont ils vont picoler
un petit peu et les ouvriers bavarde
évidemment qu'ils racontent ce qu'ils
viennent de voir est ce qui vient de se
passer donc tout ça ça va jusqu'aux
oreilles du maire ça va à la mairie
quelqu'un le répéte au maire et le maire
exige de voir ce qui a quand même quoi
donc ils se présentent à l'église il va
voir se tenir c'est pas très longtemps
après c'est peut-être quelques heures
après quelque chose comme ça et il
demande qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans le
publier donc sonia lui dit va rien
c'était des parchemins et dans les
boîtes y avait quoi que des vieux
parchemin anciens et seniors 10 qui va
les vendre comme ça ça va permettre de
rembourser le prêt qu'il a fait à la
mairie donc le maire a du mal à le
croire et ils exigent d'avoir de voir ce
qu'il y avait dedans et qu'on lui
apporte
les parchemins qu'ils puissent les
examiner ce que saunière fera quelques
jours plus tard il va lui apporter des
calques où il a recopié tout ce qu'il y
avait sur les parchemins donc là c'est
compliqué en fait de savoir si c'était
vraiment ce qu'il y avait dans le pilier
ou pas parce que se tenir très bien pu
prendre d'autres parchemin et puis les
décalques et alors c'est juste des mots
en atten qui a dessus c'est pas des
dessins ou des choses comme ça et les
apporter au maire tout mr le maire ne
lui même pas le latin mais on ne sait
pas il a trop eu le temps de passer et
appartenir personne a pu ouvrir les
boîtes et personne n'a pu déplier les
passionnants n'empêche que dès le soir
même et pendant plusieurs nuits comme ça
on voit que toute la nuit il ya de la
lumière au presbytère l'endroit où vit
saunière aux villes curé il ya de
l'activité nocturne toute la nuit
pendant quelques jours et après quelques
jours saunière rappel les deux maçons
pour venir et il leur demande de
desceller une dalle qui est pas très
loin de l'hôtel une seule date une dalle
précise décèle la dalle est en dessous
c'est creux et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
des choses qui prennent galles il ya pas
mal de choses mais directement souvenirs
fait comme la première fois il dit aux
maçons maintenant mes parts et c'est
rien c'est rien ça vous intéresse pas
donc il sortira rien devant eux eux
n'ont pas le temps de bien voir ce que
c'est évidemment les maçons il se
demande ce que c'est donc demanda
saunier à sony avec la cnas et des
vieilles médaille qui viennent de
lourdes ça n'a aucun intérêt et les
pousse encore à l'extérieur le dos le
lendemain saunière pas à paris il
rentrera que cinq jours plus tard et là
andy bell qu'est-ce qu'il a fait là bas
on ne sait pas il le dire à personne ils
seraient potentiellement aller à la
bibliothèque nationale il n'empêche que
le jour même de son retour
à partir de ce jour là va y avoir une
sorte de cinéma qui va s'alterner un
jour sur deux avec lui il marie en
protagoniste je vous dis un jour sur
deux où je devrais dire plutôt une nuit
sur deux une nuit sur deux lui et mme
arrivons dans le cimetière ils ont
incarné ils ont des fils des choses pour
mesurer et ses visions avec des torches
des bougies il passe toute la nuit deux
dents y creusent des trous ils feront
des petites notes y prennent des mesures
ha ça c'est sûr c'est à tester parce
qu'il ya deux plaintes qui ont été
déposées auprès de la mairie et qui sont
accessibles qui ont été écrites dans le
conseil municipal dans les relevés du
conseil municipal donc une nuit sur deux
ils font ça et l'autre nuit vous pensez
qu'ils dorment que nenni une nuit sur
deux quand ils sont pas dans le
cimetière marie et saunière s'en vont à
pied au plateau de razz ça se trouve à
peu près kilomètres de là ils partent
avec de hautes complètement vide sur le
dos et quand ils reviennent très tôt au
petit matin le soleil s'est déjà levé et
on a l'impression que ce qui porte c'est
un petit peu lourd donc tout le village
commence à se poser des questions alors
vous souvenez du début de l'histoire ça
commence vraiment en 1891 quand il fait
le prêt au niveau de la mairie qui
commence à faire les premiers travaux
tout ça ça dure jusqu'en 1897 où ça
bascule très rapidement il ya un
changement complètement d'attitude et
même un changement de vie de train de
vie de plus rien n'est comme avant
niveau de saunière et le mari je
rappelle que ses seuls revenus de
l'époque c'est les 25 francs qu'il
arrive à collecter sur une année entière
avec les quêtes qui fait dans l'église
pourtant le mec commence à plomber et
quand je vous dis flambent ça va flamber
grave si ça s'appelle pas un péché de
luxure ça doit pas être loin de ça ils
achètent un terrain à côté de l'église
donc ça se calme une dépense même pas la
comprendre par rapport aux revenus qu'il
a il fait construire dessus du villa une
villa de trois étages mon petit pote il
faut également construire une tour néo
gothique et il achète juste à côté de
chez lui une grande maison pour marie et
puis là je vous parle d achat qui fait
mais le train de vie les dingues c'est à
dire que le gars
on est en 1897 il fait importer du rhum
de la jamaïque parce que ça fait plaisir
quand même il fait venir des cantatrices
des grands artistes des musiciens pour
donner des petits concerts privés chez
lui bon même même en prenant en compte
les mille francs qu'il avait emprunté et
qu'il avait commencé pourtant investir
c'est c'est raufast comme comme train de
vie c'est pas possible il n'y a pas que
vous et moi qui nous nous posons la
question à ce moment là c'est à dire que
l'église la grande autorité de l'église
elle aussi elle se pose des questions et
y vende tout ça et elle commence à lui
demander des comptes elle lui envoie des
courriers etc et lui soit il répond pas
aux courriers soit il fait traîner soit
ils envoient des danses des dossiers
incomplets mais il fait exprès en fait
de deux pattes ou renvoyés de pas
réellement donné d'élément sur comment
il fait pour tout ça parce que ça c'est
la première question d'où viennent les
finances et puis ben pourquoi ils
s'autorisent à faire tout ça parce que
c'est pas très catholique en fait en
tout cas c'est pas cohérent avec avec la
vie minimaliste que l'église attentes de
l'un de ces curés au final l'église
cherche pas à comprendre il est déchu de
ses fonctions 1911 et quatre ans plus
tard il est inculpé donc en 1915 pour
détournement de fonds avant de revenir
en arrière pour s'intéresser vraiment à
d'où vient cet argent comment ils
faisaient c'est quoi le bail qui a
derrière sachez que lui une fois qu'il a
été déchu de ses fonctions et inculpé en
1915 saunière est mort deux ans après en
1917 personnes s'y attendait une en plus
marre et non plus une attaque cérébrale
c'était radical est justement au moment
où il meurt tout le monde veut savoir
quand est ce qu a lieu l'ouverture du
testament parce qu'on se dit forcément à
l'intérieur du testament il a dû
expliquer des choses il a dû peut dire
tout provient toute la moulasse
c'est quoi qu'il se passe et kolda et
derrière il ya forcément des réponses on
ouvre le testament il n'y a aucune
réponse il ya même presque des nouvelles
questions une chose est écrite par
contre dedans c'est qui fait don de tous
ces biens n'ont pas à l'église parce
qu'encore une fois la ville à la tour la
maison de marines daila pas acheter ça
au compte de l'église un il accepte il a
acheté tout ça avec son argent à lui
donc ça devient sa propriété à lui ce
qui est est ce qui est assez étonnant
quand même pour l'époque et bien tout ce
qui lui appartient il est tout à marie
qui va lui survivre encore 36 ans et
pendant ses 36 ans marie encore en vie à
la limande beaucoup les rumeurs alors
elle dit qu'elle ne sait rien
ou alors parfois elle dit qu'elle sait
des choses mais que là pour l'instant
rien dire parfois elle dit à d'autres
personnes un jour vous révèlerai le
secret du pouvoir phrase très
mystérieuse elle dit qu'elle sait
comment rendre quelqu'un très puissants
du jour au lendemain mais à part des
promesses et alimenter comme ça toutes
ces rumeurs sur la provenance du trésor
qu'on imagine que posséderait saunière
attendant elle ne dit rien de concret et
bien le jour où approchent la fin de vie
de marie et et comme là pour le coup
c'est pas une attaque cérébrale on le
voit venir à les malades et c'est pas
tout le monde reste près d'elle parce
qu'on veut savoir donc elle est rarement
seule et même au moment de son dernier
souffle là où elles pouvaient plus
beaucoup parlé on a installé une sorte
de mégaphone au niveau de sa bouche pour
amplifier le son si jamais juste avant
de mourir à le disait le trésor est à
tel endroit où le trésor proviande tel
endroit n'a rien rien elle est morte
sans rien dire mais on est le 29 janvier
1953 la seule personne vraiment proche
de saunière qu'aurait pu savoir quelque
chose est décédé à ce moment alors la
question est ce que saunière devrait
trouver un trésor c'est une vraie
question qui se pose parce qu'elle
s'appuie sur des faits sur la région en
1339 justement il ya des moines qui
était venu ratisser la région à la
recherche d'un trésor il venait faire
des fouilles la nuit parce qu'il pensait
que potentiellement les wisigoths qui
avait été chassé par clovis avait pu
venir ici et peut-être il aurait pu
cacher un de leurs trésors où tout leur
magot dans les montagnes en attendant de
pouvoir aller les rechercher pour être
plus mobiles donc on sait que les moines
sont venus dans la région fouillez
peut-être il a trouvé ça le neveu de
saunière parce que oui il avait un neveu
dit qu'il avait vu aussi des des lingots
d'or bitumée sur une table au niveau de
la tour magdala c'est comme ça qu'il
avait appelé satour quand il était petit
là aussi c'est un témoignage est-ce
qu'il a pris des choses pour les des
lingots ou est-ce qu'il appuie des
lingots en tout cas ça alimente la
théorie du trésor mais on va y revenir
les lingots d'or bitumée y sont
intéressantes parce que quand on est
plus chaud de la comptabilité de
saunière on voit qui consommait
énormément de pétrole et le pétrole
c'est très utile quand on a besoin de
dissoudre le bitume donc ça marche pas
mal avec ce souvenir d'autres pensent
que sony aurait trouvé le trésor des
rois de france qui aurait été caché dans
la région plus précisément à
rennes-le-château il ya très longtemps
il aurait été le cas chez la part
blanche de castille et un autre trésor
qui potentiellement et dans le même coin
c'est vrai aussi c'est un endroit c'est
un peu de temps intel tu peux aller
creuser il ya trois trésors
potentiellement visons d'abord voire
même quatre d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya le
trésor des cathares mais il ya aussi le
trésor des templiers qui potentiellement
et aussi à rennes le château des petits
creux sur cette région c'est hallucinant
il ya des personnes qui pensent que le
christ d'ailleurs seraient passés par là
bas et qui aurait potentiellement son
tombeau avec plein d'objets à
l'intérieur en fait il ya une partie de
la population qui pense que le christ ne
serait pas mort crucifié et que du coup
il se serait enfui avec marie madeleine
et qui serait arrivé à rennes le château
et donc qu'ils auraient encore vécu là
bas et qui du coup il sera enterré là
bas a que dans son tombeau on trouverait
des choses incroyables comme le calice
etc alors il serait pas arrivé là bas le
christ juste avec marie madeleine il
réussit martel hasard avec lui essayez
en vivent là bas et en ayant eu une
union avec marie madeleine qu'il aurait
donné naissance à un fils et ce fils
serait la première personne de la lignée
des mérovingiens et cette légende elle
est alimentée elle même par les
mérovingiens qui cherchait un petit peu
à justifier leur ligne est en fait à
appuyer un petit peu leur légitimité à
l'époque donc c'est une théorie qui a
été avancé et kiki était une vérité
pendant un temps en tout cas pour les
mérovingiens alors je vais pas vous
faire tout un passage dessus mais si
jamais vous avez l'occasion de lire ou
de voir il a été adapté en film le da
vinci code qui était sorti en 2004 vous
allez voir quand fait toute l'intrigué
elle se base là dessus en fait sur
rennes le château justement et sur cette
théorie du christ qui vient avec marie
madeleine et qui va avoir un enfant là
bas bref la théorie du trésor c'est la
théorie qui semble la plus logique
on va y revenir mais juste avant c'est
pas la première fois qu'il ya un curé
qui dépense autant d'argent et qui a
autant de richesses avec lui on y lit à
d'autres précédents il ya d'autres cas
il ya la vg lice par exemple qui a été
assassiné en 1897 il dépense énormément
d'argent c'est pas trop d'où ça venait
donc il a été assassiné son son meurtre
n'a jamais été résolu aujourd'hui mais
on sait que le voleur chercher quelque
chose qui n'était pas de l'or de
l'argent ou des biens revendables en
tout cas pas de ce type là parce que
toute la maison a été fouillée et et on
a retrouvé pourtant dans la maison des
grandes quantités d'or on a trouvé aussi
dans l'église que j'ai ici occupé donc a
priori c'est parce que le voleur
chercher on sait pas trop ce qu'ils
voulaient ou pas ça a été un peu fouillé
mais il ya une théorie peut-être gélis
aurait été un maître chanteur peut-être
qui faisait chanter quelqu'un donc il
est probable que la personne qui
assassine l'abbé gillis en fait viennent
chez lui le tue pour qu'il arrête de le
faire chanter fouille un peu pour
trouver les éléments qui étaient
compromettants pour lui avec lequel la
belle glisse le faisait chanter à côté
de gélis et saunière on trouve un
troisième curé labelle idée qui habite à
rennes les bains et qui est un intime de
saunière on sait qu'ils se connaissent
on sait qui se boit beaucoup et on sait
qu'ils font souvent des petites
excursions tous les deux au travers la
campagne du coup il ya une autre
question qui se pose est ce que ces
trois personnes ensemble est ce que par
hasard elle n'aurait pas des combats
d'un sésame ya pas vraiment d'éléments
qui permettent de le dire mais il ya
encore plus intéressant que ça et pour
vous révéler cette chose là il faut que
je vous dise un truc c'est que saunière
on est sûr de deux choses chez lui c'est
qu'il était beaucoup radin et peut-être
un bon escroc radin c'est sur le mec
passé son temps à décoller par exemple
et les timbres qui avait sur les lettres
de metz qui recevait pour les revendre à
des philatélistes et même le coût de ces
travaux vous savez quand il fait quand
il fait des scellés la table de pierre
et judas c'est pas aussi faramineux que
ce qui a été écrit il ya même de fortes
chances qu'il ait fait venir deux maçons
mais qui sont même pas maçon en fait
deux ouvriers non qualifiés d'espagne
des gens un peu miséreux qui ont fait
comme ça les travaux vite fait et qu'il
a quasiment pas payé donc n'hésitez pas
un gars qui débourse et des sous et
c'est important de comprendre ça pour la
suite est ce qu'il faut vous sachiez
également c'est qu'en 1913 il contracta
un crédit auprès du crédit foncier
pourquoi je dis c'est vraiment important
parce que 1911 c'est le moment on
devient interdit de pratiquer son
activité de curés sont activités
paroissiales 1915 c'est le moment où il
est inculpé mais ça on s'en fout un
petit peu deux ans après qu'ils puissent
plus travailler il se retrouve vraiment
sans dessous obligé de faire un crédit
les sacs étonnant si vraiment il a
trouvé un trésor si vraiment il a amassé
énormément d'argent comment ça se fait
que dès qu'il a plus son poste yp pu
vivre sachant que kanga son poste son
poste il ne rapporte rien quoi 25 30
francs par an de par les quêtes c'est
vraiment rien du tout et bien c'est là
où on va mieux comprendre le côté
escrocs qui est la théorie qui me semble
la plus bien l'abbé saunière aurait tout
simplement fait ce qu'on appelle de la
simonie la simonie c'est le trafic
d'indulgences imagine moi je suis un mec
j'ai plein de sous il se fait n'importe
quoi dans ma vie mais des trucs genre
pas bien du sort matin il ya un moment
donné on dirait t'es malade ça risque
d'être la fin sauf que moi je suis un
mec qui fait des trucs pas bien mais
bizarrement je crois quand même en dieu
en la religion au paradis à l'enfer ben
là je vais chercher un curé par exemple
saunière qui est capable contre une
grosse somme d'argent
de me libérer de tous mes péchés de me
donner le grand pardon parce qu'en fait
comme le curry re timing en fait direct
avec dieu il veut dire en fait louis
c'est bon ils passent et dieu et fait
d'accord donc c'est possible qu'il ait
fait du trafic d'indulgences est à dire
que on lui demandé l'absolution de tous
les péchés en payant est livrée aux
quais pouf pouf
c'est bon baho au paradis il ya une clé
qui t'attendent alors ça en plus il ya
des éléments qui permettent de
confronter ça parce que on sait par la
propre comptabilité de saunière qu'on a
et push et vérifier que souvenirs passés
très régulièrement des petites annonces
dans les gazettes religieuse partout
dans l'europe un petit peu partout qui
fait ça qui a besoin de faire des
annonces pour dire elle je fais des
messes cdma sport toi tu connais moi et
les gens me connaissent et c'est comme
ça qu'il avait des clients qui venaient
de partout ce qui explique d'ailleurs
qu'il décollait sûrement les timbres
parce qu'il avait vraiment des termes
qui venaient de tous les pays mais alors
pourquoi avoir cherché dans les
cimetières pourquoi avoir attendu dix
ans pour pourquoi tout ça s'ils sont
sans revenu c'était pratique et la
simonie parce que du coup un trafic
d'indulgences une fois qu'ils aient pu
curé qui lapide paroisse il peut plus le
faire donc à partir de 1911 il peut plus
faire du trafic d'indulgences et
recevoir des sommes pour bénir comme ça
quelqu'un qui sur le point de mourir
pour lui assurer le paradis du maire a
priori aucun client qui est venu se
plaindre après cette pratique comme
petit business comme sommières arrive en
1885 à rennes le château ils découvrent
trop le truc qui se met un petit peu en
place admettons pendant deux ans
peut-être qu'ils aient déjà du trafic
d'indulgences avant de venir à rennes le
château en tout cas moi je pense qu'il a
dû commencer par 1887 ce qui fait que
durant deux ans il commence à amasser
pas mal de pognon en fait avec sa petite
escroquerie tu vois mais comme il est
plutôt radin il n'a pas besoin comme ça
de dépenser et puis ici que de tenir
s'ils dépensent ça va pas correspondre
avec la vie qu'il a là bas donc ça va ça
va vraiment me pointer du doigt et
risque d'être mis en péril donc il
attend patiemment jusqu'en 1897 pour
commencer à dépenser son argent et
qu'est-ce qui fait durant ces dix ans
quelque chose dont je pense mari devait
être au courant il fait semblant d'avoir
trouvé un trésor et c'est là où il s'est
brillamment malin ou c'est plutôt un
très très bon escroc c'est que je crois
qu'il n'a jamais menti en fait saunière
de ce côté là parce que lui n'a jamais
dit qu'il avait trouvé un trésor quand
les deux maçons viennent et qui décèle
la table en pierre posée sur le pilier
sur l'autel le pilier crever dedans il
ya des parchemins de trois boîtes etc je
vous ai dit lui il dit directeur mais
caché ça partait et tout donc tout le
monde pense qu'il a un truc à cacher en
réalité c'est extrêmement commun c'est
même plutôt la norme que tous les
piliers d'hôtel soit creux et qu'à
l'intérieur liés des parchemins et des
boîtes avec d'autre part chemin dans
lequel on écrit des bénédictions des
prières ce genre de choses ça se fait
c'est très courant mais eux dans le
village ils ne savent pas ça donc lui il
a attisé une forme de curiosité mais
sans matière puisqu'il a dit à déboîter
départ chemin ensuite je pense que sous
la dalle la talent qu'ils ont décédé
quelques jours plus tard quand les
affaires revenir je pense que c'est lui
qui a mis réellement des médailles qui
proviennent de lourdes est pareil quand
ils ont descellé à nouveau derrière
saunière je pense ils ont vu saab il a
appuyé en mode lent mais on s'en fout
etc je pense qu'il a simplement voulu
alimenter la rumeur et ça a fonctionné
puisque tout le monde en parlait dans le
village et tout le monde se posait la
question et qu'on me disait ce que vous
allez trouver un trésor et 10 et non
techniquement effectivement et demandez
pas quand après il a fait des fouilles
un petit peu durant la nuit dans le
cimetière qui partaient en excursion sur
le plateau avec les autres il revenait
au petit matin je pense que tout ça
c'est de la mise en scène pour encore
une fois faire naître la croyance et le
sentiment qu'il avait trouvé un des
potentiels trésor qu'on aurait
potentiellement pu trouver dans cette
région et du coup dix ans plus tard 1897
il commença flambée grave pas tout le
monde se dit ben voilà depuis le départ
on avait raison il a trouvé le trésor et
les deux copains dont je vous ai cités
tout à l'heure je trouve que ça marche
avec cette théorie je pense que eux
aussi pratiqué le trafic d'indulgences
puisque quand même gelis on le sait
était vraiment soupçonné mais soupçonnée
en mode bien bien de faire du chantage
sur certaines personnes par rapport au
secret qui savait sur cette personne là
donc c'était aussi peut-être même un
trio d'escrocs mais on en revient que
sur saône hyères lui en tout cas arrive
à justifier contrairement aux autres
toutes ces dépenses par non pas ce qu'il
dit mais par le fait que les autres
disent à sa place et un village entier
témoigne à sa place je crois que
vraiment s'il avait cherché un trésor
il y aurait fait ses recherches
discrètement la nuit il aurait pas
laissé le presbytère allumer les volets
ouverts il n'aurait pas cherché une nuit
sur deux dans le cimetière en creusant
des trous devant les yeux de tout le
monde au point que ça gêne tout le monde
tellement il faisait du bruit que les
gens portent plainte auprès de la mairie
il serait entré discrètement avec ses
hôtes il serait rentré plus tôt pleine
nuit plutôt que à chaque fois au petit
matin à la lumière du jour devant tout
le monde pour que tout le monde puisse
bien les voir pour moi on y voit au
contraire la preuve d'une volonté de
bien montrer aux choses qui les sert et
potentiellement de cacher quelque chose
ils le rendent est le plus visible
possible il a créé du mystère et de ce
mystère est née sa propre légende et ça
ça marche bien avec le fait qu'en 1913
il a put une puisqu'il peut plus exercer
depuis deux ans donc qui peut plus
pratiquer les messes dons qu'il a plus
de commandes pour les simoni pour les
place au paradis payante mais
c'est décevant fait des seuls payant
pour le paradis directement il peut plus
faire ça depuis deux ans donc il a plus
de revenus parce que il laissait
habitués à un train de vie plutôt faste
et donc ils crament tout ce qui leur est
durant deux ans et a glissé qu'il a un
petit peu dans la panade et c'est pour
ça aussi qui peut jamais répondre à ce
que lui demande l'église parce que il
peut pas dire qu'il a trouvé un trésor
sinon ils vont lui demander de voir le
trésor donc il n'a pas vraiment détourné
de l'argent contrairement à son
inculpation de 1915 puisque encore une
fois l'église ne lui apportait pas assez
d'argent ou son activité de prêtres pour
détourner cet argent là par contre il a
vraiment escroqué grâce à son statut de
pure et il semble que des escrocs il ya
une deuxième escroquerie je trouve sur
l'escroquerie à partir de 1899 il ya un
homme qui vient une grande visite pour
la première fois qui va revenir très
régulièrement dans le village un
aristocrate qu'on appelle monsieur
guillaume pourquoi monsieur guillaume
j'en sais rien alors qu'en réalité il
s'appelle jean stéphane 2 ce bourg chant
stéphane de habsbourg monsieur guillaume
vois pas trop le rapport c'est comme
ceux qui m'appellent olivier n'a rien à
voir il fabien je m'appelle fabien donc
lui vient en 1899 il va revenir
régulièrement et il va prêter déjà dès
sa première venue vingt mille francs
quand même beaucoup d'argent à notre ami
saunière et ce que je pense c'est que
comme il est venu en 1899 donc deux ans
après que sa mère ait commencé à flamber
un peu tout son pognon je pense qu'il
est venu attirés par la légende de il a
trouvé le trésor je pense que saunière
des hypothèses en personnel mais je
pense que saunière lui a dit en fait
j'ai trouvé une partie du trésor mais la
chute suis là je suis bien bien bien
dessus mais j'ai besoin de moyens et je
pense que ce monsieur guillaume a
commencé à le financer en fait pour
l'aider à trouver tout ça et qu'ils
devaient leur rembourser une fois le
trésor trouvé peut-être il avait un deal
genre on fait moins que moi tous des
choses comme ça et je pense qu'il a
soutiré pas mal d'argent à ce monsieur
guillaume en plus de l'argent qui se
faisait sur le trafic d'indulgences donc
oui saunière a priori a toutes les
chances d'être un énorme escroc qui a
créé la légende sans jamais le dire d'un
mec avait trouvé un trésor pour
justifier ses dépenses c'est pas mal
c'est pas bien mais c'est pas mal ainsi
s'achève la première histoire de ce
nouveau format alors attention à ce
format sepa cabinet curieuse cabinet
curieuse on s'attache à des événements à
des objets là ce format là je veux
vraiment un peu ce que vous et bellemare
m'attacher à une personne à son histoire
à partir du monde à la fin de son
histoire il s'est passé un truc tu vois
un tac tac quoi tu es tombé à plus de
formats tac tac j'ai hâte de voir si ça
vous plaît parce que moi ça me plaît
beaucoup de faire ça donc
j'ai hâte de voir en revers pour vous
alors comment je vais le voir je voulais
dit au début de vidéo ça va dépendre du
nombre de vues donc n'hésitez pas
regardez la vidéo que vous venez de
regarder moi comme le format me plaît je
vais la regarder aussi on verra ça sur
les stats n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo
aussi en vrai rat un message positif et
à partager la vidéo aux gens comme ça il
la voit comme ça moi je comprends que
tout le monde aime ça que je continue à
faire des vidéos et surtout abonnez-vous
pour pas rater les prochaines vidéos
bref hâte de lire vos commentaires
savoir ce que vous avez pensé que ça
vous plaît
comment ça va chez vous la météo d'hier
pourquoi je prends une voix comme ça en
prenait sans nous et à très bientôt ciao